all right let's go to Susan in Kansas
Cindy hi Susan welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hi Dave how are you doing
today better than I deserve what's up in
your world so we have this financial pit
in my family and it's my mother-in-law
my husband and I have been supporting
her for pretty much our whole marriage
which is going on eight years and a few
weeks before we got married she got into
some trouble and we were lucky enough to
be able to assist her with her trouble
at that time and we've always been able
to assist her but I guess when is it our
turn to I guess start taking care of
ourselves so the concern that I have is
you know she's been living with us for
eight eight years and we still don't
mean she worked for a small company part
time because she feels like she doesn't
need to work full time because she's but
in her dues
she wants to start working for herself
instead of working at a job sorry so
there's nothing wrong with her other
than she Wow well why are you let her
live there she she at first when she
moved in she said she would help with
our children and she would watch them
you know free of charge which you know
is a big financial relief but about a
year ago she like well I really need to
focus on starting my own business which
is quilting then chance to focus on
moving out yeah see she's about to be 55
what kind of trouble did she get in
eight years ago
Oh like jail trouble Jay she went to
jail yeah for what embezzling oh good
okay all right and let me ask you
something um I'm real confused as to why
you all think you have done her a favor
you've not done
a favor she has no dignity at all she's
a movement when whenever we try to tell
her like you need to get out of our
house and we've given her like a you
need to be out of our house by the end
of the year she's like you don't know
the sacrifices I made for you growing up
kiss my butt that's the answer to that
welcome to being a mother and you're 50
years old and you need to have an
identity and dignity and you need to get
out on your own so she's a travel agent
for guilt trips so tell her kiss your
butt it's time for her to get out your
husband's a wuss eight years he's put up
with this seriously dude
here's weed put up with it seriously man
up and tell your mommy to go get an
apartment that's ridiculous because this
is not this is not done in love this is
done in dysfunction it's a toxic
situation this mean lazy woman is ruling
the roost this makes me angry for you
and for her nobody has loved her enough
to make her go have a life okay you guys
got a look you got to put her out Susan
okay you have to for her sake you know
you the problem is she has she has
parlayed the selfish view of life into
eight years of being a parasite and
that's after being an embezzler and and
she's done all of this under your roof
what are you modeling for your children
here you know it's this is this is not
good for her it's not good for you it's
not good for the children no one is
winning in this it looks like on the
surface that moms winning but the
problem is mom's not getting dignity and
mom's not got any sense of Destiny and
sense of control her whole goal in life
is to start a business quilting right
now and she's 50 years old I mean
there's nothing wrong with quilting and
if you're going to quilt you need to do
it like in Mass on eBay and make a
living doing it but Trent you know the
way I translate that statement is she
doesn't intend to do squat that's what I
translate that do you translate it
that way I do yeah this is the in other
words I intend to do less than I've been
doing and I ain't been doing much am I
wrong now am I saying what you've been
what your heart was already saying and
I'm just being meaner no no we just want
to be able to you know have lifted off
of us yeah yeah and so I think you have
to develop a plan and so what I'm going
to do is number one your husband has got
to be very strong I'm going to send you
a copy of a book called boundaries by
dr. Henry cloud okay and when you read
the first two chapters of that book you
guys read it the first night you get it
you go in your bedroom put the kids to
bed you close the door and the two of
you sit in the bed and read you read one
chapter him him read the other chapter
you you will be laughing and crying
because it's going to be your biography
because you're going to go yeah I'll
leave this is exactly us because it you
know everybody the reads that book by
the way has a little bit of that it's
not just you I'm not picking on you but
there's no boundaries here this woman
does not respect your boundaries she
doesn't respect your life and so then
your husband has to in spite of his
mother's negative reaction and in spite
of all of those things he has to
establish some rules and that will be if
it's me by the end of next week we will
announce that by the end of January you
will be moving out we are systematically
going to get you an apartment we're
going to work together on that we're
going to work together on getting you a
job and we're going to work together on
showing you how to do a budget and live
and we want to help you any way we can
help you we're not going to support you
anymore and you're not going to live
here anymore and it's not because we
don't love you and if your way if your
view of our loving you is that we have
to give you money then that's not a
relationship that's called prostitution
when you have to pay for a relationship
right okay okay and it's a loving act
and we're not going to be mean about it
we're not going to be nasty about it but
we're going to say January the 30th
you're going to be in your new apartment
and it'll be the lease will start
February the 1st and so that gives us a
little over 90 days to work on this and
we're going to lay out a plan and this
is over it's changing it's going to be
awesome mom you're going to love your
new life and you're going to and if you
don't that's your decision but you're
going to
this and if you can give her a couple
thousand bucks to get the deposits and
stuff in place maybe pay the first
month's rent don't cosign the lease but
you know if you put up the security
deposit or you give them some money for
the deposits for the utilities and get
them set up and you know maybe you pay
for her to see a career counselor and
whatever but she's leaving okay this is
what you wanted wasn't it it is it is
everything I've ever dreamed up house so
tell your husband you don't want any
more flowers for Valentine's Day this
year you just want a card from him that
says mom's gone it's some of your going
you're not respecting you're not
honoring you're supposed to honor your
mother your father Bible says to honor
your mother and father yes it does it
does not say to honor their misbehavior
if your mother's doing cocaine are you
supposed to honor that well no stupid
you're not supposed to honor that so you
people that say you have to honor their
misbehavior and their toxic view of life
that's not accurate
if your parents are abusive you'll honor
that you can honor the the office of
motherhood the office of fatherhood but
maybe maybe this particular person No
you